Drama queens of his news have again taken the hair.
On Sunday,
on France Three,
the boss of the Greens talked about media
on swan.
In current value,
we leave this ideology all day long.
You have only debates between people of
the extreme right and the extreme right,
without any plurality.
Will the drama queens recover?
It kept them all day to these news.
The slip of the national secretary of europe ecology,
the greens,
marine tondelier,
twenty and a half hours.
Bayonnet of the media,
in this case, lord,
karine tondelier,
nine hours on france three,
so we will come back to,
uh, marine tondelier,
marine tondelier,
two-hours and thirty,
what she calls the bollorée strategy,
seventeen hours fifteen,
our channel cnews,
twenty-nine hours fifty,
twenty-hours,
twenty-one hours,
twenty-one hours twenty-one hours twenty-one hours twenty-one
hours twenty-one hours twenty-one hours twenty-one hours
twenty-one hours twenty-one hours twenty-one hours twenty-one hours,
twenty-one hours,
we will take five minutes,
twenty-three hours,
what we think of marine pandelier.
Vexed, offended,
offended.
Drama queens,
ma'am,
you are disrespectful.
Ah,
you have to tell marine tondelier that we are not in cuba,
it's a shame.
What she tells me,
I'll do without it,
eh,
marine tondelier,
this reasoning,
it's totally bogus,
lie to proximation,
she says big,
she says mistakes,
she tells lies.
What porridge,
what porridge,
she says anything,
she says anything.